hi everyone thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
second episode of studio xml sessions
branding for designers this event is
presented by the press room and
supported by the design singapore
council and the national design center
i'm felicia from the design singapore
council and i will be your mc for today
today's program branding for designers
will discuss how you can harness the
power of branding to stand out in the
business and carve an identity for
yourself and your designs our panel of
speakers will be sharing more about
themselves and their approaches in the
first half of the session before we move
into a panel discussion and q a segment
for the second half so once again please
feel free to post questions for our
speakers to get more advice and insights
on the challenges of navigating your
brand today
and with that it is my absolute pleasure
to introduce our panel for today we have
with us nathan young who is both the
co-founder of grafant a forward-thinking
lifestyle brand and the founder of nasa
neon design a multidisciplinary design
consultancy practice
joining us is also jin li co-founder and
designer of jin lee studio a
contemporary women's wear label that
prides itself on creating thoughtfully
designed pieces and last but definitely
not the least we have larry pay founder
and creative director of and larry and
independent branding and design studio
moderating our session for today is
kelly chang founder of studio sml and
the founder and creative director of the
press room a publishing and design
consultancy so without further ado i'll
hand over the time to kelly to
officially kick-start the session so
kelly over to you please thanks felicia
uh hi everyone thanks for joining our
session today so before we start i just
want to share a little bit about what do
sml project is about uh studio xml is a
progressive archival project that
envisions to
archive the singapore design history
through interviews with singapore
creatives it is also meant to be a
research platform to study into the
business of design in singapore uh
through these interviews with designers
uh to find out why some students stay
small some become big and so and so
forth um also i'd like to share is that
we are currently having a abstract
features art installation a platform
that uh hopes to uh
uh sort of share this the ideas behind
studio xml a traveling exhibition that's
happening at lasalle college of the arts
right now till end november so please
check it out
and uh at this moment i would like to
invite everybody to participate in this
poll because it will help us to make
these talk sessions more
meaningful and fruitful for you so can
everybody help us by just
putting a quick tip on the your answer
and then submit it to us thank you
okay so uh it looks like today we have
the majority uh
from uh graphic design and uh also a
very good mix of people from spatial
design product design fashion ui ux and
others
and then
most of the people attending this talk
uh
oh more than 10 years actually and also
some less than three years so i think
it's really a good mix of
practitioners and students i believe
um so hopefully i hope that today's talk
would uh benefit both of you because
maybe uh some some of the design studios
are still young and to start how do you
bring yourself to the next level and all
that uh maybe today's talk will give you
some answers from our veteran designers
and uh for the younger ones who are
hoping to um
to kind of start your own studio and all
that i believe today's succession will
also give you some good
insights into
how you can start your own studio and
how you can run your business and in
fact i would like to invite all of you
at this point to also check out the most
important thing of single sml is of
course our website
www.studiosml.net where you can actually
read about
viral interviews of jin lee nathan young
larry pace a very detailed journey
journeys in design and also many other
creatives in singapore so uh
log on to the website or listen to the
podcast on spotify
studio sml
channel yes okay so without further ado
i would like to invite our first speaker
today nathan young to share with us his
insights about building his brand
nathaniel design and his retail a very
successful retail
outlet at hunan
rafam nathan over to you
hi everyone uh thanks for coming in
yep so as what um kelly said can you
hear me right i just kelly
yeah not very clear okay
so i've been doing a furniture for the
last 25 years
and when i say furniture i'm dabbling
with retail designing and exporting
furniture and then recently i've been
doing more of an art slash design
for furniture objects
um so how do i start um
i got a couple of brands with me and all
of them has kind of sort of a different
identity i think one of the reason was
to
some of the consumers don't really
know in depth of who i am or
or what i do so it's easier for them to
know the brand like graffang is a
it's a brand that focuses on good design
it doesn't mean that they have to know
about what nathaniel do or or what my
design philosophy is so for graf it's
always about how we source good design
furniture into our show and whatever
that you see in the shop is always
already been curated
by the team in grafang and we try to
keep ourselves young and fresh and
always spot new
brands and to bring the shop so that's
what uh it's more in that but that's
what graffang always stands for even the
name that we had i mean we invented the
name
and
it just sounds good and we just want to
be confident and we just want the buyer
to also be confident in doing up their
house
so before that um
home furniture are pretty like
i would say a bit um
kind of of of of uh
hard to get and the price is really high
and um
it's very exclusive and i think the fund
is trying to make it more
casual in that aspect so we are pretty
new we are about 12 years old right now
so griffin always have that fresh young
spirit
so and then jump to my own design
services nate young design which i
designed for overseas brand
that one is predominantly who i am my
creativity and how i market my designs
overseas
uh how do i say i also developed with a
lot of
clients with singapore clients like
jewel changi airport
and park uh dsg
um
how do i explain uh
i think
a lot of netanyahu design is mostly like
i just do what i
i'm strong at designing furniture
and able to
deliver
what i promise
like when i design something i make sure
that i'm able to deliver on time i'm
able to develop that that promise of of
good quality and all that
um
i don't specifically kind of sort
out to
brand myself
um
yeah so
i'm not sure why i might in this topic
but then i think i just do uh what i can
uh the best and always deliver and i
think that kind of like
able to
brings me a good rapport with
customers and then also referenced by
them to get more customer
so
it wasn't a very strategic move most of
the time i mean i just be myself and
and and just be nice to people so
i'm not sure it's
like my brain but
most of the time i'm what i am so
i don't try to be um
i don't try to be like other people so
yeah
other than that i have furniture brand
that i do export it's called folks for
lkf
it's a whole much to
um the
craftsmen that produce my items in
malaysia
so i name them folks because those
wooden they are wooden pieces of
furniture because most of their designs
are very humble it's very day-to-day
kind of a functional wooden furniture
it's nothing loud
and it's very humble so maybe that's a
bit of a branding i mean just like the
folks what it meant which is normal
people right
so
so again that ties up to the
design philosophy that i had for that
collection which is very simple
functional wooden uh good quality wooden
furniture so that's folks
um so i think that's about all sorry
yeah i think we'll chat more later but
that's all for me
thank you so much nathan could we now
invite jin to join us on screen please
i'm jin i have a woman square label with
my partner tamil we are established
actually in history in 2011 so the brand
is about 10 years old i always say that
half of it is me finding out about
myself
and unlike nathan we we had to learn
quite quickly what the customer want
from us and adapt the brand to it
slightly even though i started out with
a vision this is what i what i'm going
to do but it had to change because
honestly because as a consumer brand we
had to kind of like understand what
the consumer market is about
so
i think
that is something that we kept true to
ourselves like what uh
nathan mentioned before that's
what you feel like is your soul and we
have that so between me and tamiya we
are both designer i'm fashion he's
industrial designer so there is that
kind of uh
work that we
a bit more known for which is our
pleated pieces and um but we felt that
is a bit of like where we can come you
know he he does his thing i do my thing
and then we come together and you know
put the final pieces together
and
but one thing we do believe is that we
strive for good design as well even in
the form of clothing and
it's not so much the styling part and
that's not us that's not me actually
because that's the fashion stylist job
it's really more talking about the
actual piece that that piece
and
we have a tag line that we kind of like
string together at one point just a bit
of guiding ourselves say making fashion
that matters but really it comes from
the ideal idea of like we want to design
something that looks good on the body is
important to us looks good on a hanger
without any form of marketing just
purely on the hangar and also look looks
good in a gallery so it can be it can be
admired by itself
and um
we because of the roots of the brand we
always have this
resort-ish kind of at ease look to our
to our garments
and um
it's quite important it's quite
important element to us because
sometimes people say hey
you are quite shapeless and like okay
but i think because that's the that's
the dna that's who we are that's what we
designed for so it tends to try to keep
that kind of dna with us because i
mentioned the brand actually started in
israel so we kind of like uh try to
bring in bring in those elements of
natural light where you have like sun
drenched this dusty color which is very
much television kind of color scheme
also like in our new store in greater
city like we try to design a space with
the id wing collaborative and to have a
space that feels a little bit like
outdoor space which is kind of like what
we really want to have in an indoor
space
and even that vibe you know it's kind of
talk about branding but branding is
everywhere like uh also the service like
we try to wrap off this uh dna on our
service staff so you have to be warm
they have to be helpful and
less corporation and a bit more
human-centric i think that's what we are
trying to kind of like put our branding
across over because of as a consumer
brand a retail brand we do need to have
that so people walk off not just looking
at the shop by saying oh that service
reminds me of a in a very warm
mediterranean fuel or something like
that
and
we one of the our design process is that
we do put the wire in the middle of the
of our design process so
and um we tried to incorporate like a
bit of like what i mentioned to dna also
like little things like dance for
example you see quite a lot in our
campaign and that comes mainly from uh
in the beginning days in israel when we
designed the clothes and i found that
people were buying the clothes to wear
it to weddings
and in israel the weddings are a bit
different from singapore it's less
formal it's a it's very much you go to
the venue you see a dance floor and
those women just stick up their heels
and start dancing so we and then once i
realized that i realized that the
clothes got to
you know be able to for them to move in
it so they would start testing the you
know the
mobility of the clothes so by dancing in
it so that's became the dance test and
that's what we kind of like try to
incorporate into the campaign also part
of the branding in um eventually because
uh you know we saw kind of like speaking
of above is to kind of like uh put a
little bit of element here and i remind
people what the brand means
and uh in terms of like
um
what we've what we feel about like our
our the way we behave and all that i
think we're definitely leaning more
towards the quite confident
and nathan also mentioned humble you
know like that's something that we do as
well
that we feel like being authentic to the
brand to the vision
and we believe that you know this moment
that we're dressing she doesn't need to
be aspired to be someone else but
herself and that's something that we
respect you know and i think being
respectful is something that we try to
do especially especially in our branding
because like uh you know respect can be
many things like
towards the environment towards our
customer sometimes we you know like as a
pro marketing
gimmick sometimes we ask like why don't
you do a flash sales limited edition for
grab so open a window of time that
people just buy but we don't feel like
it's in line with that belief we don't
want to encourage impulse buy and also
we feel like our customers are not just
people that fall into this kind of like
uh you know just out of respect you know
like we don't need to push her to go and
shop like that right so that it that
interaction should be more genuine
so
and i guess to sum up um
even though we are
[Music]
we are designing we are designers we see
ourselves a designer but we do sell
commercially so that's the bit that we
have we have to balance quite carefully
because we're finding a voice that
resonates with our customer as well and
also our design ethos because we have to
first
separate ourselves from the brand so
meat and tamiya is not
the brand right so jingle is the brand
that we have to represent but at the
same time the brand is separate so that
was probably the biggest toughest audit
that we have to do in terms of branding
and it buys no mean finishing or you
know it's just a matter of work in
progress all the time but i think to for
me to sum up i think i believe that
a designer and studio can efficiently
brand themselves if they stay true to
themselves that i agree very much and
also being coherent in the
in the branding messages in the the kind
of campaigns that you run and i guess
just overall things that you do
so that's all my sharing
thank you so much jyn could we now
invite larry to join us on screen please
oh hi
okay uh
uh uh
i've just had like three talks this
month i was joking to everybody uh
pardon those who was joined not the
first time
i'll just keep it simple
i started
the company in 2005
just like a simple idea graphic design
studio
over the course of the next 10 years
2015 we've
uh i've gone on this path to become sort
of like branding consultant
we see ourselves more and more as
consultants because we do less and less
design work but ultimately ironically we
still design company
because it's a language of design right
um
a lot has changed
over the
years
and i think i'll reserve that for q a if
you have any questions about it
in a nutshell or brand essence it's
about design with sole purpose
um
we've done a lot of work from
advertising the digital to what i view
and
eventually i figure out that well people
say purpose is very important of course
i mean
but i feel that
without soul in everything we do
you're just another piece of
design clothing
or furniture or whatsoever so yeah
that's kind of like how we inject our
difference
with every project every client
everything that we do
um and i also believe that we
the more we do it the more we leave our
mark
um by the good it delivers rather than
the the way it was designed
uh having said that it mirrors our
philosophy in the company
and that with the more like
progressively over the years right
uh while i try to take on this
usual path of oh we grow bigger and
bigger our projects get bigger and
bigger
and so on and so forth but it's kind of
the opposite of how the product we've
taken
um the clients can get bigger but to me
it doesn't make a difference
so we have this um billionaire project
in japan to this
crypto swap company in
san francisco
it to us is the same it doesn't matter
how big or how small our roles
um become
more important more deep but at the same
time we grow smaller and smaller and
kind of more and more into the shadow of
sort so we make ourselves disappear over
time
yeah and um
for
our client
we are still 100 word of mouth from day
one
we don't pitch we don't go out and get
clients we're very very blessed in that
sense
um we don't judge the client like i said
earlier where they're from how big they
are
but a very simple
word that links us will be respect you
come to us you respect us we respect
your business and we're all about doing
something better
um for the world for ourselves for the
audience so we will just take on
projects like that and how i have an
internal um
filtering system
is that we're putting the contract that
we are a company that will give you one
idea
one concept one design but of course you
can have
about three rounds of changes but
everything is one
recently we added one more that we
verbally said but we put in the contract
all stakeholders key decision makers
leaders owners
must be present in every meeting that we
request
so if you don't then we no matter how
big on how much money will not take it
on
and um
yeah the team is very small
i've gone through over the years of
trying to be everything i've made
mistakes along the way that where
oh you know we got to grow this
department i think i can do this i think
and do that
let's take on this let's take on that
and in the end um we realized that it's
not the way to do it
so i've kept the team very small there's
five of us
um
kind of like
nickname or some of the friends close
friends told me that i'm a little bit
like
the studio is a little bit like batman
and batcave so i'm kind of like a batman
here
um
i can do kick-ass gadget i can
probably save the world but
you probably don't see me
posting shouting or jumping around
telling the whole world
so yeah
in a nutshell how we brand ourselves all
these years it's
by
the loud healer is actually the client
um the work that we deliver the good
that he delivers but for us we just keep
more and more combo and more and more
quiet along the way
yeah
that's kind of in a nutshell
that's it
okay thanks thanks larry
bye and see
uh okay i'm gonna start the first
question uh to to all of all three of
you first uh because all three of you
have also uh retailed uh in other
countries uh
gene of course started in israel
shanghai
nathan has worked with international
brands larry you have your faculty so
and so forth so i want to ask what
what's the difference between branding
in the local market and
in the international market
do you have different strategies or do
you have to
take different steps to to ensure that
you are able to sort of
transit from singapore into the
international market
maybe outside nathan
yeah let me just speak um
like for nathaniel design because i
think there are a lot more here which
are young designers and when i talk
about grifon it's more of a retail
business so maybe it's easier to talk
about musical design
so
i know that at the end of the day
businesses just want product to sell
so when they look for me for
design is mostly uh my desire ib to sell
and i think that's the key thing that
they have been coming back and asking me
for
for designs
so i'm not sure about branding
whatsoever at the end of the day you
just have to deliver maybe i mean for me
so
yeah if you ask me the question of is
there a difference how i brand uh
for the export market of singapore
market i i think it's always the same
it's like i deliver at end of the day
so
that's about it
okay how about jin you you have quite a
lot of experiences in israel shanghai
um so maybe you want to share a bit
about this sir i speak for retail then
like because we do the same
we do the same
look and uh but what's interesting is
like in different places they seem to
say different thing
like i mentioned in israel they find us
quite elegant in singapore they are
quite resolved so
but for the same thing so for that i
feel like it's uh
you know how different culture different
society perceive
the product itself
in terms of branding we don't do like a
different set but you do need to do that
for marketing and you need to do that
for just
the product you know for example for
clothing it's really about sizing like
so you have to make sure you have the
sizing and all that but in terms of
branding i don't feel that it's really
changing so much
um larry what's your take
oh it's a big question a lot of things
in my head but um trying to keep it
simple
i i think um
increasingly we see a lot of
globalization
it's not nothing new but i think
very importantly whoever you are be the
brands you design for yourself
uh you need to stay true to who you are
and um like what gene mentioned the
localization comes in the form of like
china you're using their people using
their you know
kol or col
whoever that could speak to the audience
but i think the localization comes in
all this little social bid advertising
pr and so on and so forth but
increasingly
this i always believe there's something
intrinsically human that we we connect
on that level
it's almost like how
netflix and hbo and all this
has kind of flattened the world right
like traditionally you wouldn't think
some something like squid game would
probably create a resonance with the
global audience but
you know so uh i i strongly i strongly
believe in that
whatever you do stick to who you are
um you know don't ban yourself don't
change yourself so much to the point
that you're pandering to
the new generation of shoppers or buyers
or audiences
but be who you are and find the right
orders or rather the right audience will
come to you
um i actually like to pick up
uh on something that jin uh shed in her
interview for discussion here june you
mentioned that for the growth of a brand
uh it doesn't always have to be about p
l like how much money you make or that
it should always be about the numbers
that the growth of the brand can also be
looked at in terms of other aspects
maybe you wanted one to share with us
about that
i think it's depending you know who's
the stakeholder of the display because
the brand is owned by us so therefore we
are the only people that is uh
answerable but i guess the bigger your
i guess the bigger your you know group
of stakeholders are the the more complex
it starts to be
but for us because we are driven by not
just numbers you know so i think
fundamentally we want to do things that
are meaningful that uh
they have a soul you know so we're not
chasing for more shops just to open
everywhere and like uh also we can sell
more clothes i mean that's not who we
are like uh if that's who we are i think
we won't be speaking here today you know
like uh
i think
it's mean that in the end of the day i
mean it keep coming out staying true to
yourself you know have a soul you know
it just keep coming up because i think
that's what designers are about that in
the end of the day you look inwards and
say this is what i want to do this is
what i feel i can change the world in my
context yeah this is what uh i feel like
it's meaningful so for us we are looking
for things like that so i very often ask
like is yeah oh can i do something that
is not like just reflective of my
numbers can i also have like
environmental pnl or
you know so those are important
especially nowadays like there's more
and more talk this way you know so it
doesn't feel like i'm so alone or you
know that vision is stupid or you know
it's not so reasonable and you feel like
the world is progressively looking in
that direction which is very encouraging
you know so it because that believing
business uh can do good you know as a
force of good as well i think that's all
very encouraging for me like uh i think
i believe designers can change the world
i do
nathan i'm going to uh continue a bit of
that question so in terms of growth of a
brand you you have actually grown a
division to quite a successful point and
then now of course you uh you start from
scratch growing refund how different is
it uh how how do you think that the
brand evolution for air division is
different from drafting right now
well you're asking me very tough
question
yeah because you are you're very smart
i i don't know i think a lot of things i
do is just gut feeling so i think i have
a very bad answer for you
but you're asking me how does it transit
how is the difference between graphing
and air division
yeah i think the core business structure
changed a lot because when i'm in air a
lot of like
my designs are
i mean a lot of our products are
designed by me and produced in southeast
asia well it's got fun we import a lot
and there's only like my brand folks
that's in the retail shop so i mean
running air for first 10 years i think i
learned a lot of lessons of what to do
and not what to do
so when i when i started graffang about
11 years ago i kind of say that i can't
do anymore producing my own design i
mean and and
sourcing and all those things because
there's a lot of work um quality issues
also
so once i run the fun i know that i just
want to streamline a lot of process
so
a lot is more of the structure of the
businesses uh for the branding i think
at that time um i started up with a very
small shop and opened up in a warehouse
so i don't really care about like you
know like a wallpaper very stylish kind
of like posing
kind of pretentious look anymore
so i think i gained like a lot of
confidence when i started graffang like
just
just do it differently
um
and i i think a lot it's not just the
branding it's really the core business
of
how you run your your your
your businesses and how you communicate
with people and also your stakeholders
so although this talk is about uh brands
uh branding i hope the audience don't
think that it's it's the one the only
thing that
that you know makes you uh good or or
have a longevity in your businesses in
fact i think brand should come to the
last like if you get everything right
brand should just just kind of uh fall
into the right places
so i hope the audience here don't think
that you know branding is
something that you should do it because
you need to do it but rather
you're just presenting who i know that
being authentic
so yeah
can't hear you kelly okay larry there's
a question from the audience for uh for
you
how do you go about branding yourself as
a graphic designer especially when you
have to create
very different works of all sorts for
your clients
these days i like i say to make it
simple we call ourselves a
brand
branding consultant
because we don't
really want to take on design jobs
per se
but back then yeah i mean
we started kind of early where the
internet wasn't like today
information not so easily available so
it's kind of like who's the old song we
just bang around try this try that and
eventually we got to where we are
but yeah we don't go around
advertising ourselves or rather telling
people we are designing studio these
days with more like brand consultants
as a result
uh the next question most of the time
flows to what
what are some of the things that you can
do for me
so a lot of times we talk like
like a doctor
or a friendly doctor
to see what problems we have then we try
to help you in that sense
so as a result the things that we do can
turn into something else all together
and
a lot of times we end up talking and
linking people up and then we don't get
the money we don't get a job
most of time we get a job later on
because they realize that yeah you are a
good
doctor who kind of pointed me to the
right direction the right people and the
right medication and in the end
yeah i mean everything comes together
right i want to talk to you to
maybe create a hospital together you
know i mean that's kind of how i
i do my business
yeah
okay thanks
jim there's a question for you uh from
the audience it says uh hi gene love
your signature please do you ever feel
that having such a strong signature
sometimes limit you
how do you manage when you want to
introduce new styles beyond what you
might already be known for
it's a good question we get that i
remember like uh
there's two side of it like one of it is
like
yeah if people know you for something
that's good
you know better than being known for
nothing so on one hand that's that and
then the other thing yeah on the other
hand is a bit like oh
is that like is it miyaki so we also get
that as well for me i don't know i don't
have that you know like sometimes you
know in terms of like for example area
of sustainability sometimes it's always
ask biodegradable or recyclable but for
me resources are resources raw material
material i don't view it that way
designers we are trained to use material
and work with what we need from the
material so i try to not view it in that
manner you know we we will keep working
keep designing keep designing
to the next item that we work on you
know kind of if i hit a call and people
really like it and all that stuff so i
don't try to over analyze it it's good
we have someone remember us for
something and just keep going like uh
you know it's not like limiting us at
all just keep going
so we're constantly working on that
though we love plates though we just
love the way that you have to really
work with it i mean it's not obedient at
all it's really not like you try to
design the the thing that we do quite a
lot is designing around a form designing
around a body so that it actually
flatter rather than flatten like so
really try to make it work around the
body so in that way like you know like
you wouldn't imagine like how the
pattern looked like on the blizzard item
it just doesn't make sense on
traditional patterning because it
because the plate doesn't make it make
sense so those are the elements that we
enjoy a lot and i personally it's a
designer that love how 2d become 3d so i
enjoy that process i enjoy patterning
and just working with fabric
manipulating it so those are what i
enjoy so it doesn't matter if it's in
trend today or tomorrow but it's
something that we always continue to do
as long as we can because that's what we
enjoy doing so i don't know to answer
the question i guess it's uh
yeah just keep going yeah just keep
working on what you like no
okay thanks uh nathan there's a question
for you from the audience it says
hey naden kudos to you for having worked
with so many uh big brands around the
world herman miller linear rousseau
living dima divani uh et cetera
how did you get uh
how did you start getting them to notice
you
ah so
so there's a lot of things that you need
to do uh most of the time i say yes
unlike larry
um no when i say yes i'm always open for
conversation right and then see what i
can do
and
it's a long story because it started
from a international magazine by tyler
brulen the wallpaper founder
he got this magazine that he featured my
studio work and then
it kind of like snowballed and leaving
divani saw the items
so lily dimani wrote to me and said they
want to pick up some some items to
develop and that's how it starts with
them
but i also literally like go to milan
show and cold call
so you know in the past we burn our work
in a cd city room
and you go to different booth that you
you want to work with different brands
like cappellini
munchies and all that and just pass them
the cd rom that you know i'm from
singapore can i speak to your creative
director this is my work and then try to
get a name cut off their name
so there's a lot of
thing that i
i've done before just to get myself
noticed up there um and shamelessly
someone just email
um
and shamelessly just ask friends who
know them
or friends with friends who know the
people uh the the brand's owner
so it's really no
uh
no straight um
rules to how you get yourself noticed
it's really quite
old-fashioned like i literally have to
be there and get myself featured in
magazines and all that
so
[Music]
i think i've been very lucky i'm not
sure i'm not saying that if you do the
same you will get the same result and
i'm sure i'm not the most talented
furniture designer in singapore
southeast asia but somehow
maybe i
like as i said i always open and try to
have a conversation and always be
as nice as possible
and
like just keep joking i think my my
secret recipe is i joke a lot
and be likable
because i i know i mean i i i taught in
the south so and and one of the
professions study i i went to the
the class and saying don't be an
basically
it's nothing to do with your name card
it's nothing to do with graphic design
something to do with your fashion
whatsoever first of all don't be an
and i think that has been
yeah
by my belief and how i treat uh most
people and
try to be as funny as possible
but i think it has to be genuine like
you have to be authentic and genuine and
also my exposure to different things
live music i like firm uh i like
sculpture i like architecture and all
that and i think all that kind of helps
me as a creative person
yeah
did i ever answer you like i think i
always didn't answer what your question
is yeah i think i think you kind of did
because i think it's also uh to to this
uh person who asked the question but i
invite you to read naden's uh interview
on studio sml because uh to summarize
him he said don't be shy just be thick
skin and just go out there yeah i think
just with thick skin but don't be
help me
very annoying so i think i'm
sensitive enough to know that i've
pushed it too much and just keep my
mouth shut
so i think you also need to know how to
torrent like
like stop asking you know people are fed
up of you and and you know step back so
i think you have
to have a lot of empathy and understand
how people work
yeah
okay this is a question from from the
audience again and i think actually it's
a bit uh quite relevant to jin lee and
larry who just had a sort of a new
branding
um so the question goes like that any of
you had to do a rebrand of yourself at a
certain point of your career
so maybe i invite larry to uh start the
answer first
yeah so
it's a work in progress
you i kind of have it in me to
constantly
kind of be uncomfortable
[Music]
but
start with a vision you must always try
to go towards it
um
maybe a whole lifetime to get there so
yes i have been doing that and um
even right in the beginning i'm not
happy being a graphic design studio
because we were always handed out handed
down from
brand consultants
like oh you know they need eight months
to a year to rebrand you guys do the
rest of the
stuff first
and after that we'll be fed with all
those things and say we do this you
don't do that even a lot of times we
disagree with it so yeah yeah i kind of
felt that why can't we do the job that
they do and that um inspired me to
pull the team
pull out our socks try to learn new
things try to work our way up
and we did that so i remember over the
years i've pissed off people uh some
people felt like you know
i can't follow larry anymore because his
chin
his ship is changing
direction you see uh why are we doing
all these research and talking and
workshops and what the hell
there's not much design going on anymore
physical design ourselves
yeah so and over the years i've done
that and one of the biggest one would be
in 2020 when
uh
kovit struck and we were
quite blessed we had a very good year in
but uh we had a lot of time to
sit at home right and i got the team
together and we brainstormed about and
we did design thinking we did rebranding
for ourselves a lot of it is internal
uh only external thing is probably you
see the nl logo instead of a larry
because i'm in the process of getting
rid of myself
um yeah that's and of course like
internally it's very important to
rebrand to know
if your compost is still correct and
your ship is still sailing to the right
direction so do that very often check on
yourself check on the team check on the
market sensing to see where you are
yeah
why do you want to get rid of yourself
in the brand though
uh i mean it's
the most obvious thing i always draw
point reference it's like o m right like
nobody say oh goody and matter anymore
so even you know next time when i'm oh
i'm not wrong or
whatever and it doesn't matter anymore
it's just
i just didn't change the company's name
because it's too complex
so i just kept it in larry but
the symbol itself is an l so
like what i said earlier
the mark itself
it's like maybe a batman's mark right
it's just the good that we deliver
rather than me or the design or anybody
else yeah
okay uh jin i think you recently just
did uh
rebranding and also um you started make
right so actually this is related to a
question that one of the audience is
asking as well
um jyn chance by an exhibition at the
national design center over the weekend
but didn't have time to check it out
uh is that a new label you are working
on
so uh perhaps you can share a bit about
why you decided to rebrand and what's
make all about
okay um
i have too much to say and just try not
to lose my thought and uh
let me say about losing himself so for
me that is the same process as well
because it's something wrong with
namesake you always feel like it's a
person one menstrual but it it's not
it's a team and finally i always say
like it's a you know it's not me it's a
team of people and tamiya my partner
will always say he named the brand after
his wife you know so we kind of laugh
about it like just to you know make
ourselves feel a bit like more
better about it but uh i i really do
think that it's not uh and process i
mean you know just designing the logo is
really not in process because over time
you change your business change but it
still remain i think the core value as
you every convention like you ask
yourself or is that still what i'm doing
and you know that's what i believe in so
that really doesn't really change if not
i think it gets sharper it gets uh
more
accurate i think and uh you kind of need
the branding that go with it right so
you can't need to make sure a bit more
updated and all that just like your
business strategy if you don't update it
you'll be slightly out of date and make
is one of that mic is actually developed
during our incubator period in tbi
which is led by taft and it was looking
at really areas of the problems of our
industry really like uh the whole the
whole over production change of uh
customer expectation and all that so we
were at that time we asking the same
question like hey how are you know it's
not like people say why are you doing
incubator you are like a few years in
the business you're not startup anymore
but you can't feel yourself like that
can you i don't i don't think we can i
felt like business are changing very
quickly the marketplace is changing very
quickly if you don't look ahead then
you'll be left behind so i think that's
why that's what uh we look at for our
branding that's what we look at for make
make is actually uh
the whole idea is about making in shops
so if if you think about all this uh
uh painter or this shoemaker or key
maker that it's like this little hole in
the wall kind of a concept and how this
skill and craft eventually will be lost
to bigger you know establishment and all
that that's what we're trying to do but
not saying that we will keep
you know singapore will never be a
production country so what we're trying
to do is design around that design
around the whole production we're we're
producing production module so instead
of like thinking okay you have a piece
of garment that you're going to make
everything is done we chop it all up we
decided to produce part of it and not to
do part of it so make is actually about
making store so we can actually reduce
the
production lead time to
an hour you know by putting everything
together so the the bottom line is that
we didn't want to have a sewing machine
in the store so that it doesn't remind
people of like a tailor shop okay then
you make my it's made to measure so we
want it to be still quite designed so
everything is kind of like thought
through to make it uh making shock
really and we're still playing with
plates because that's kind of what we're
known for and we also thought that it's
quite a lovely craft to show people it's
super low tech i mean that's the amazing
thing about it that we really love about
a super low-tech piece of paper yeah you
know
you can heat it up and you've got what
you need and we really love that process
and we thought like if we can modernize
this craft right we can actually
localize it i think that's the whole
idea and kovic kind of like really fall
in the right place for the whole project
to happen because localizing was one of
the key thing because having your supply
chain being you know kind of like mess
up how you find products locally and all
that it became a big thing and it kind
of like felt the right time to be doing
that
so make is actually
a lot of those you know about like bring
back the old
craft ish in a way but in a modern way
uh bring back local
bring back design but really to do
design not in just that static form
design everything we just pretty much we
design uh production modules we design
the way we retail we design everything
that we can design
so some sometimes people think design is
aesthetic but it's not it is like just
graphic design i mean like logo designs
the end of it as everyone tried to
explain the whole business
shaped the logo in the end shape the
name in the end
so yeah that's what make is about really
like uh obviously the exhibition
downstairs is a bit more in depth
because it shows a little bit of our
research because when we had the idea at
tbi right we presented our page and uh
we didn't have much we have like just a
few mock-up and just to say the idea is
feasible and so we went into that
research okay we have to look at the
stimulus
we talked to some guys in syntax to help
us uh technologically or like uh
scientifically what can be done to heat
up the data so we went to that looking
colorings we look in using plates in
different way of like sizing it and all
that so we look at different things so
it's a research basically that we did
for the idea of that we will be able to
make this in shop
so so you're welcome to check it out and
understand more
so yes uh jean is having this show at
national design center let's check it
out
um okay again i also remember something
that you said in the interview that
for you what's important is fashion
as a fashion designer is what fashion
design means to you as a craft
rather than the whole marketing around
it
and i think what you said also resonates
with nathan and larry who emphasized
that you have to keep
doing good work and it will
bring you places so my question to you
is that
the advice to young designers who just
started out do you think that uh they
should just keep on doing good work and
honing their craft is that the way to go
or is there some other things that they
have to do
to be a successful designer
uh i speak for fashion i don't know
about the other industry when i started
what i did was nothing looks nothing
like what i do today you know like my
first collection was a flop i did a
winter weather and realized that in
november and australia i stood wearing
t-shirts so everything was a flop like
it was very bad i tried to do linen
after that thinking that oh wow you know
maybe the climate was it but it didn't
work people find that they didn't
understand why it's crumpled it was a
lot about pivoting and understanding i
sit in the shop in the in the one of the
shop that i target i want to sell here
so i sat in front of it like i think
nathan was talking about cold calling it
happens you have to and just sit there
and just watch women go in and out and
watch their body shape and watch what
they
trying on and all that just to
understand because i was designing for a
market that i they have no idea i move
into israel a month and i say okay you
know let me try to start a brand so i
didn't know what the woman was buying i
didn't know what advantage i had so i
had to learn quite quickly and i feel
like that is the
perhaps that is designer anyway we are a
bit of a problem solver you're presented
by
something challenging and you want to
overcome it so i think we all took
different steps so the step that i took
or many of us probably have taken at
some part of our life might be a bit
hard and
just really like trying to know it by
analyzing studying looking observing
analyzing trying to come up with
solutions so i do think that i don't
know like yeah you can keep hitting that
wall but if it doesn't if it doesn't
give way then something is wrong you
have to move as well so you can't be
blindly doing it but i'm sure that you
have the common sense which most
designers are equipped with in a way but
just need to understand when to look
away and maybe you try enough it doesn't
work
try something else you know but i'm i'm
sure you have it in you i believe like i
think that's what designers are about
anyway and just to stay it's a it's a
fine balance between understanding who
you are
tuning it and going back to it and you
know moving it but i think in the end
for me i do really
still feel like that is not a it's not a
sprint it is a long distance run and i
always say like i do this to the day i
retire therefore it gives me a sort of
like
i'm calm in it because i know that i'm
not going for that fast run i'm doing it
i'm going to improve it i'm going to
work on it so
so the other question just now was
talking about please right the same i
don't have that mentality oh you got it
and you know what's next but i keep
doing it i think as long as you do what
you believe in what you like you always
go back to it even though you have a you
have a good seller i think book writer
have that no you get a bestseller
blockbuster and then after that what can
i write no one would love anything i
write anymore but you just keep doing it
because it makes you go like it makes
you feel like home and every time you
don't know where you're going just go
back home and you'll get there
thanks uh nathan you uh in your
interview was so like when you were
at air you are like a designing machine
every week you will design
that was some furniture
was young yeah try to get a going
and all that right so um so do you think
that for a young designer you just keep
on owning your craft homework do good
design improve what else do they have to
do
um
i think this one sounds really bad but i
think if you are a good designer
you should be a good businessman i'm not
sure
larry or jin you will agree or there are
some people that will totally disagree
because i think a lot is about problem
solving isn't it
and a lot is about empathy and
understanding and managing
issues and connecting all the dots
so i always say like what i think
generally or larry say like it's a it's
a system i mean design is a system
it's not about product it's not about
graphing it's not about fashion
it's about working
and connecting all the dots so it's
looking at things with a very systematic
ways of of of chilling out the final
result
and i think if you are
a good problem solver as a designer then
i think you should be able to run your
business uh really well unless it's bad
karma then i don't know like you know
it's come up um
so your question again is uh when i was
at air what else do you have to do to
just be very good at your craft to be a
successful yeah so i think first of all
really the core of it like we really
have to be very good at what we are
doing
i i think if you want to have a
longevity in your business as a designer
you first of all because you can only
lie so much if you are not good you use
branding or whatever i think you can
only like so much and people are not
stupid but if you want a longevity in
your business i think the core things
that you really have to be good with
your design
so they give you the very long runway
and then the second thing is really it's
about businesses it's about being
practical
it's about managing people it's about
listening to advice and be nice to
people
um
yeah
okay uh larry i also remember in your
interview that you shared with us your
first project when you started out with
the yoga ware branding
it's a
nightmare client from the uk right
i'll never forget it
so i believe you were already a good
designer then as well so
but uh what do you think being good
alone uh is that enough
i think it's a given
like i think the rest of them all say
the same thing is a given but the i
think that's true the true essence of it
is to find out what you are
blessed with what you're gifted with
what your gifts are
then
tackle it from there
find out who you really are and what you
want to do like for example i'm the
first few to sign up for tick tock i've
take top account i have i still remember
when facebook came out royston said hey
let's connect on facebook
so i sign up i was the first to sign
everything but
it's just not me to be in there so i
didn't do it
so these days i think
there are a lot of shortcuts and um i
have my
cousins nephews i have
my best friends
nephews
they i
watched them grow up and then now
they're like
rockstar you know that thick talkers
they make probably make more money than
than my best friend he joked so
there's a lot of ways you can make money
and be famous
and the brands are looking at it that
way too you know like
um again sorry and now it's very hit to
talk about sweet game like you know
you just
the the lady in the shows just walked
the catwalk as a model she get paid as a
model and after school games she became
the lv's brand ambassador
you know so
it's not that she's
in terms of talent
they probably have seen her right i mean
she can ken box is beautiful she can
walk after that thanks you just get paid
right but
suddenly people see you differently
you know so the way your talent lies
it's probably she found that yeah i can
act
and i could stand up from the sea of
models
so
it's really about part of what we do as
branding is to discover yourself
deep in really discover yourself deep
ask yourself hard questions
do a survey talk to your friends talk to
people
and in the end you should find out where
you should go and how you should do it
yeah because i think don't
uh don't
listen to all men
like me talking it's my way is the hard
way and you could have
instant success
you know just as long as you have your
head firmly on the shoulders and you
know unless you can
jump into the metaverse and just forever
be there next time
other than that otherwise like one
nathan said you gotta be
human you gotta have empathy still
you know not hide behind the screen and
the keyboard warrior and you can just be
an
so i guess um i'm also looking at some
of the questions about
how i mean someone some of them
mentioned that i i'm an established
brand so i can turn down clients
yeah it's hard because when i was
starting out same thing i just had to oh
this sounds fun oh great i want to do
this i need to make money
so
there's no one solution to everything
but
i've come to learn that by being true to
who you are and be very very focused on
what you do
i mean
things took a turn for us
because we were angry we were frustrated
with the
bad clients and projects that we're
doing with carrying our hair out people
are quitting and
you know that's where you have to ask
yourself what is going on
so they eventually find that the people
who are attracted to me and this studio
or
needed something to keep them alive and
if that changes and you're not sure
yourself it's just taking on
jobs
and in the end you lose your soul you
lose your stuff you lose your client you
lose everything but don't let people
bully you in a nutshell
clients come to you they tell you oh
cut your budget do this dude i'll give
the job to you then something is wrong
be flexible of course not saying i won't
cut my face but
you know what's the reason for this talk
about it which is why like i mentioned
earlier that stakeholders
are very important
um
we make that mistake too
this year we had
you know almost closing a hundred
percent happy
2021 business was great
um projects were good smooth but we have
one percent one client
that we ah
oh my god you see
so
we suffer from that too and we are in
the process of being professional trying
to resolve it
deliver
and
move on and
put in the clause next time
yeah so so make sure you get to talk to
the key stakeholders
every project
like i said with my clients us all these
we feed their timing
at night or something in early in the
morning we resume we talk
because the little things that even in
mandarin you know like chinese client
they speak um
from the heart then you kind of know
what
really is that turn key here and there
and that's when when you have one option
to the client of course i mean that's us
but you don't have to sound like us but
when you show them they will say
yeah
that's right but maybe the color is too
dark maybe a little bit bigger maybe
that's fine
yeah
versus
you like me young like larry
how do you like you know someone else
it's it doesn't work that way right like
you're attracted to his big ears and his
big nose
he's definitely gonna bring you luxury
and fortune so don't go don't go with me
go with him
so i regret respect i have got respect
for larry
i mean he has very high morale standard
so unlike him i'm
i'm quite shameless i'll take him really
bad projects actually i will i will
pitch for free no i'm joking
i'll do all that
i think i'm just like
just want to be hammered down like just
want to feel like
i'm psychotic i just want to feel like
being bullied sometimes so that i learn
something from it
but i'll take on
like if the money is good or whatsoever
i'll take on and i thought those
experience is good
when i'm younger i mean now yeah depends
on money um
yeah i thought all experience is good
regardless and it makes me
able to handle nasty customers also
so i do take on like really shitty
project for actually customer
the thing is just for branding sake okay
for those who really do want to learn a
trick about branding is
whatever the
i shouldn't share this in public
whatever the public talk about you the
press or the media are the information
that you give to the media
so if you have a really bad project or
customer
um and you have to sustain your business
you need to pay your stuff you you you
really have to be like prostitute and
take on the project and because you need
to pay your stuff
um and you just don't have to mention
this project just keep it in the drawer
so
especially when you are a a new company
i think it's very hard to able to
choose your customer and
and you know and do a decent business
and have longevity and keep running so i
think the way is really to accept
and be okay
that sometimes
you need customers who pay well and
it's okay because you're actually not
surrendering your integrity
you're just surviving
so i think it's okay to
to you know
not like larry i think it's okay too
i think it's okay to succumb to treasure
and because we are i mean we're living
in a society in singapore that's a very
high cost of living and i understand
that a lot of young designers have to
make ends meet and you have to take on
those projects just don't tell people
that you take on this project yeah
larry there's a random question for you
someone asked
larry do you like tick-tock do you do
tick-tock dances too
okay no that's a simple answer okay
there's a question for all three of you
uh hey designers would you like to share
more about your team
what kind of talents do you need in a
design studio company and how did you
team up together with the team members
of course
as i already said he has five people in
the team
what were their missions in their
previous projects
your your assistants do they do nothing
i.t
what
yeah so i think it's about sharing about
you they want to know about your team
what kind of uh people that you hire and
what do they do
maybe i'll start first i hire
um
designers
to begin with
um i've of course over the years i've
tried different people
you know some really good marketing i've
also tried like business development but
um we're quite blessed in the sense like
i say
we don't need
business development so most of it our
teams are all like just imagine if we
are you know atelier all of us are
pattern makers all of us can cut and sew
and
communicate and
um
and sell the idea
but most of the time if it's very tricky
they will definitely want me to sell the
idea
but increasingly i don't have to these
days
most of them
are here because they like certain
things that the studio stands for
and i believe also that i practice what
i preach
so like the concept of venulari is to
put anything and anyone in front of me
it's i always talk about like if if it's
my concert you come i will never be like
thanks for coming to my concert but you
always be on the drums you have who on
the back of vocals on the guitar you
have
and you don't
ever hear and you and me as the vocal or
the rock star you know
so i think that's how my team members
work with me
um
if i can don't be in the picture i will
not be in the picture
and i like to empower them i like to
just
um make them all see a certain direction
where we need to go
and the rest just
do it in your own pace to get there
but i'm also a little bit like how apple
designed their hq where
i believe that we all have a life and
and part of the we all introverts here
and part of the charming part is that i
don't really
poke my noses into everyone's lives
and unlike a lot of small studios where
they're like family we're not
we're not like families i don't ask
about your husband i don't care about
your sisters
of course if you have problems come to
me i will always land on listening here
but we are very professional as in work
is work
right if you finish your work on time or
even earlier you can just go home
but during the time when we vote on
things we have to be
together in a sense yeah but it's very
clear line that we're not family we
don't share kicks together we don't want
to do all this yeah
so a bit like among
monks yep
like i kind of run the studio a bit like
a monk
in a temple
yeah
okay uh gene how about you how do you
select your team and how are they
involved in your company
and we also went through a fabric of
like
trying out different things and all that
i do feel like for small company what's
important is a
willingness to
try different things ability to think
i think those are quite critical we find
that much more perhaps much more than
if this person
is a
professional in this particular area
because for a small company you need
people to adapt quite quickly and when
they go like i'm sorry but this is only
what i do then it's quite difficult to
you know move around so we look for we
look for that you know when we interview
and we hire people i think we look for
that people who can work in small
company or if not understanding what
small companies have in terms of
challenges
and
so that's one thing that we look out for
but people who think i think is quite
important i think over the years we
begin to think more and more like it's a
very important thing to encourage
thinkers in the company i think to share
their point of view but also to work
through processes so it's not like oh
cannot be done or you know it's a
just you know convert this out or like
you know there's no solution out there i
couldn't google it i couldn't pinterest
it like less you know that kind of uh
candidate but more people who's willing
to try with not so much referencing what
been done but let's just try something
new so in that way still designers but
at the same time i'm very careful of
that because i also find that sometimes
you get a bit pigeonhole when you
surround yourself with too many
like-minded people so you do want people
who have ability or strength that i
don't have you know and i don't have a
lot of strength you know and a lot of
things that people can contribute as
well because we run retail business
that's why a big part of the team is
operational and with operation it's
slightly different
we do look out for each other
and it's very important feeling though
because in operation things happen and
you need to respond quite quickly
customer angry and
so it's to give the feeling you can fall
back and someone will catch you i feel
that that's very important for me
because if not i get high attack every
now every time i get it
do i understand your team is looking out
for you
you know you can fall back i'll catch
you you know don't worry so for that
that's what we try to build within a
team that we work perhaps like a family
but not like uh poking my nose into
their business but make sure that they
feel like i'm not the only one dealing
with this but someone is looking out
with me
so i think that's what we do when we
build our team
and but it will change as business
change as we know like we moved back
last year and we started to build the
studio i mean like bring the workshop
back so we start to look for different
people with different skill sets and
also when we open retail we found
ourselves meeting marketing much more
than ever so that's the looking for
marketing people so constant work in
progress a lot of things to learn
nathan how about you how do you select
your team in uh
neither young design and refund and how
do you involve your team in to you know
to be a part of the company
so so i at this moment i don't really
run day-to-day uh
things in grafang
but one thing i did correct is i find
the right partner which is uh i think
you guys know jeffrey
uh jeffrey can do things that i can't do
so
i think the first thing that i did was
really able to find a partner that i
know can contribute to business so right
now i actually don't run the fund that
much and jeffrey is doing every stuff
but once i teach jeffrey everything i
actually leave it to him so i haven't
been dabbling with the fun for the last
maybe four four years for five years so
jeffrey is doing everything
so about um
so so for graphene is like finding
someone that can compliment you that you
can do okay so for nintendo design i
always say that i need a shampoo girl
when someone comes to me with what i
like oh nathaniel design it's so cool to
be here i'm like no it's not cool
you got to be like a shampoo girl i'm
not going to teach you
anything you just got to work hard and
observe
and
i think
a lot of time when i look for someone it
is because they're hard working and
their willingness to learn because i
don't owe it to them
to teach them anything if
if there's a person that come here and
expect me to teach them anything most of
the time i wouldn't get them in the
first place because
they have to have that initiative and
willingness and a passion to to pick up
and i think that's the best way to for
anyone to learn and and to grow
and it's pointless for me to
force them to do something just because
it's that job or whatsoever
so
yeah so i'm looking for shampoo girl who
just keep washing hair and steal some
glances of the hair stylists how they
cut their hair and that's all okay okay
next question again from the audience to
all of you uh hi guys is there a
strategy or technique that you employ to
convince clients that you are worth the
price that you're asking for
maybe start with larry
google nathan young what do you see pay
him that's it
[Laughter]
i i there's never
right formula for that um but
i've learned from my team that we doing
the rebranding right
they did say like if a client if a
project cannot come with any amount x
amount of dollars for the kind of work
that we deliver
then we just have to say no
can we all agree on that i said yeah
cool and we've been trying to practice
that so far so good in that sense so you
have to put yourself a certain worth
right it's like if this is what it is
then
you try not to go down on that feast or
if even if we do it's a genuine effort
to say um you want to help out in some
ways
but most of time i always
become like what nathan said the
businessman and i'll ask like what if we
take an equity
if it's a new if it's a startup right so
what if i don't charge you for this but
the amount that let's say i'm gonna do
this for 100 grand it's it will turn
into equity how many percent at this
point of time if one day they get
you know acquired by
some china company and then that percent
will
be worth a lot of money
so
i've tried that many times
not one succeeded only
99 of time they ended up like
finding the money for me
so that i don't own equity in a company
so
in a way that's how i did it so i
realized yeah they can't find the money
they because if you they think you're
worth it
they will find this amount of money for
you if not then really i can just give
you equity
so you just take a gamble like my
ex-boss my mentor chris lee asylum i
learned from him when i was working
asylum first when the company started
he loves party drinking on his right
restaurant has all come to us no money
never mind you pay me wine
fmb so you know afternoon hey finish
like i was let's go go and eat
shots to the client you know so even
that itself we're not doing it for free
you're off a certain word like oh free
wine afternoon dinner
and nice meal in a restaurant yeah of
course if the restaurant closed down
then it
could be eat before your credit is up
so yeah so uh how about you naden how do
you uh command your fee
i think furniture design right timeline
we don't take outright we take royalties
that means we we
no longer a big part of designing for
european brands and american brands is
that you actually don't get the direct
pay you get paid from the sales that
they they get
so if your things sell you get become
caught right this
royalty so so we don't get paid in that
sense um
for me it's a very
weird situation because i get my pay
from different places
like i
i'm such a like prostitute
like i i teach in lasalle so i got paid
from the style i i got profound so i get
normally
paid out from kefang
and then i got royalties for all the
brands that i designed for
and
and some other shady businesses um so
no
uh so i got i got money from everywhere
that means i'm not very uh
hungry for a project if i if i'm not
interested so for me is how interesting
a project is first
whether they pay or not that is not
important but i really
like interesting businesses
projects that i will take on regardless
whether they pay or not um
up front of course they have to pay
later once they have a sales commission
and all that but uh most of the time i'm
guided by how interesting the project is
so i don't so back to your question how
do i i've never chanced upon situation
that i will have to
[Music]
um
tell them the reason why it cost so much
because probably i'll just walk away
when someone were to say hey you're
expensive and all that
i sometimes find quite insulting and
sometimes i think that they didn't do
their homework well enough
and
i just say nicely that maybe it's not
the right time
so yeah i try not to convince them
yeah
gene what's your take on this
i'm obviously i'm a consumer good
so we have our items on retail price
so obviously we get our fair share of
like wow so expensive or you know
i don't know if people say oh that's so
cheap but
i think it's
for consumer goods i think it's very
much about market placement where you
add with your
competitors and how you brand yourself
how you price yourself it's all strategy
for us we never want to be super
expensive we can't call it accessible
because i don't want to
be selling things i cannot afford myself
i don't feel like i can touch base with
that kind of clientele if i myself can't
afford what i sell so i think it's uh to
have a pricing that we we are
comfortable with as consumer ourselves
and say that yeah it's something that i
want to be
in you know level at so that was the i
guess for us it's more like homework on
like the market you know to put a
pricing on our work
but we didn't really take on projects
like what you guys are doing and you
know so therefore i never really have to
cl cost per client and never have to
done i have never have to do that so i
can't really comment on that
okay uh next question from the audience
hi speakers have you ever lost faith in
what you do or lost interest in it how
do you deal with self-doubt or refueling
yourself
uh they're losing interest right now
actually
frankly i'm kind of
tired of designing furniture for
commercial reason
uh generally good for you continue your
fashion empire
but i'm a bit kind of tired of doing
very commercial french project so what i
did is that i pivot myself now i kind of
like
trying to do kind of art slash design
project so that i can
indulge myself with
projects that's more
speculative or more sculptural that
hasn't has any commercial value in that
sense
um
yeah there's a part of me that is i
guess quite creative and i don't want to
answer to any customer about hey your
chair
can it cost this much can you table have
extra drawers can i cable management i
kind of like
sick of doing that at the moment
so i'm
doing more of a kind of art sculpture
design
project uh moving forward
and i've also started teaching for the
last four years
um so i think teaching is
still quite fun at the moment i don't
know when i'm sick of it also um
so i think most of time you have to
reinvent your business or yourself and
to do something
that you really like and and push
yourself um it can still be in a room of
creativity you know maybe i can start
producing a film or something and i
think that gets our our brain juice
going
but um i think it's important to
to just stay creative regardless whether
you are doing like furniture design or
fashion design but always engage in in
creative uh projects so for me again
i've been i'm sick of doing furniture
design and i'm doing more of a
art and education yeah
how about uh larry how do you uh refuel
yourself and uh
avoid burnout
uh um
like i think i've covered some of it
early on where we
be very careful filter
what we do
so
we're lucky that we just have one
percent of
heart pain and that's it you know the
rest of the project it's a wonderful
experience because
we uh
we like to say we work with
the stakeholders the clients the
decision makers and they tell me along
the way
how we're faring and we kind of have
this sparring session all the time and
after that we never fail to get a pat on
our backs
we get paid on time um every
every milestones that we hear we get
paid or move on we bill hundred
percent yeah they respect us in a sense
we get paid we have pets on the back we
go for makan when
when the crowd can gather again and
after the project they will always come
back and check with us
and like some of the clients where they
would work with us on a long term basis
and that itself is like a friend like
you know someone close to you where
they benefited from it and
yeah like donkey for example we're gonna
give a talk
apple store
early december
for business and we we invited them
together and you know they will share
the stage with team with my team to talk
about how they've benefited because a
lot of traditional brands like them 80
90 years they close down and that's a
reality
for them they're so hip now so relevant
and you know we bought projects where
the gen z
told us like oh i love this brand i eat
the tarts and they're so young and then
we were like yeah happy to know that and
they themselves have seen it
and the grannies uh who paid us for the
job at first they were like come quiet
i hear that for years
but now uh
even
the the mooncake festival we they sent
us home cakes from the grannies
and after three four years they finally
said yeah
we are worth every cent
so those are the things that got us get
us going
that's nice jin how do you
refuel yourself and avoid burnout
um
[Music]
for us is to stay curious i mean make is
one of them right project that we decide
that we're going to do because we
believe in it
i mean like we signed for that location
the day singapore announced
i told the landlord can you keep the
track uh the check for me no no i'm
banking already so we believe in it and
i say like okay if you don't do this
what we do right so i think we do we try
to do projects that we are interested in
i i enjoy selling in mess in some way
but not too mess like i do find that
there is challenge i don't say like oh
this is what i like i did take you what
you wear i find that it's a dance
between me and the user what she likes
and you know listening watching and all
that for me this is where i feel like i
get my challenge to to to work for her
to design for her so unlike
the two boys i don't have to pick on a
client i do my collection i launch it
you know people like it people don't so
my feedback is less
you know in that way personal issue even
though i do get upset i mean like i say
i mentioned in the beginning my first
five years was spent finding myself i
mean i had my moments that i bring
things to the shop and this just pushed
me away i mean like it's all horrible
and i cried over it there was a lot of
doubt a lot and i adopt what i call the
jewish mentality like when you surround
the people that keep telling you you can
do it you can do it because that is very
much needed if you surround with
yourself with people that say why you
bother why why do these you know why
don't you just go in company you will
never get there so it's very very
important to you know surround with
people that are positive and
entrepreneur as well so then you get the
push because you have to believe in
yourself first before anything and that
really really helped but stay curious i
think that's how keep us going
yeah i just want to add on i mean this
has got nothing to do with branding i
always think that designer has to be
perpetually positive
like i don't know maybe i'm wrong but
i always find that when i'm with
students that's always negative and all
that what they see and what they chance
upon is just no no no
and in the end they can't move like like
they just
are so negative with all the problems
that they face that they can't move and
and hence i always think that design has
to be positive and
and a strong belief that things will get
better it's just it needs to be innate
in any creative
uh person that
you have to be creative
and has agreed to and fix that
things will turn out well when you
design it uh i don't know why i say this
i don't want what you say that i want to
add on this but i just want to take this
opportunity because it's in my heart
that i want so pissed off i want to talk
to my students that you always have to
be positive and believe that it will
work somehow and just keep doing it
and this is something i got something to
add to that it's interesting point of
view because
um i i totally agree with nathan and i
also mentioned that i'm like batman
right
so i'm always dark
uh
introverted
but i think that my my way of finding
strength and balance is in the
bravery and
the need to
have your voice projected
so that power
supersedes everything else i'm not
negative
i'm just
maybe melancholic i don't know what this
described but
yeah it's it's in that sense where a lot
of people who know me think i'm funny
they say like well you know you can talk
a lot non-stop blah blah blah but
those who don't know me they will say
yeah stuck up you know you feed clients
you pick jobs and you know like this
like that but
no it's it's
you know so i i think even if you feel
like
not everybody needs to go out and do a
song and dance on top but you must
be brave enough in different ways right
if you're not gonna expose yourself to
this song and dance then at least let
your work do the song in nuts
larry i saw you answer this question but
i think that is actually a very
interesting question someone asked you
about
whether you benefited from the pmc
certification uh so it basically means
that uh the branding project you take on
the government will actually fund fund
uh eighty percent right if i'm not wrong
yeah so i think a lot of uh studios um
you know they consider going for this
very troublesome pmc certification
because
uh it gives you it potentially gives you
more uh business leads right because you
are being funded so what do you think of
that is it worth it to go for this pmc
certification
i don't know whether it's still
necessary i i'm not
100 sure but i'm guessing that you don't
have to these days certain projects
yes i've answered the question
that
we have benefited a few projects from it
but
increasingly now i think like even last
year we probably had one project that
qualifies for the grant
but the rest is not
you see so and i find that it's much
better without the funding because we
are more spontaneous with the client
right it's it's like again back to the
doctor analogy sort of thing is when
they come to you and say oh funded means
our government will cover your
hospitality
see what
and then you can only operate on the
hand on the other hand also the problem
uh maybe next time
but we
without the funding we are
sort of like looking at it from an
objective point of view and say
see the problem comes from a constant
running it's affecting your hand because
you know somehow
uh let's change the scope and do this
not that the fun funded jobs you can't
change the school but it's kind of like
every
along the way you have to tell the
officer timeline screwed up oh you know
change that and
yeah whatever you put it forward you
must deliver it
okay there's a bit of room but yeah i
just feel that it's kind of creep
sometimes a bit it wastes time right
i didn't say that but it's just kind of
like um it will be benefit you will
benefit you if you
it depends on the client again is the
mix and match right like the client that
comes to us is why i know i love and
larry's
in l studios work but at the same time
they are also what boners can
can try to get funding right
so i think it's a bonus but
yeah that shouldn't be the factor that
the determinant
i think that when some projects come
from funding
the stakeholders are not really genuine
in
in the business
in the business because it's funded by
someone i mean the government right
so they are not so because it's not
their own money
so it's not their own money they were
like uh just
they'll probably give you some report
that you're not very intense you know
it's just like okay just do something
larry you know and they're not very sick
when you get funded
most of the time i think that clients
are not very serious in the project
because their stakes are not high
so likewise never take a project where
where where you say it's free
because when a client don't pay for
anything they they don't take the whole
project seriously
and when they don't take the project
seriously the whole thing will just fail
yeah no result will come up from there
and then just a waste of time so that's
why that claws kick in where we have to
talk to the
stakeholders and all these things so we
make sure that like last year that
project
that we took on
uh in fact it was one of our best
projects last year
yeah because he's so deep into it you
know every way and then even after the
scope expanded right i don't care just
proceed you see so we kept going and
then we were paid a lot more than what
the the funding actually gave them
so
that's kind of like a case
okay we we actually have so many
questions but uh we have to come to an
end so i'm just going to ask a last
question to jin it's a fun question so
that we have end on a happier lighter
note so the question is uh jin singapore
fashion brands in the past would
traditionally hire caucasian models for
their ad campaigns to appear
to appeal to the global to appear like
the global brands
um or hire pan-asian models to make
their brand relevant to the different
races in southeast asia
seeing that you sell in both southeast
asia and israel
what influences uh
you when you select your models for your
campaigns today does race really matter
at all
no i don't think i think now i think
fashion is in the stage that we have
very careful with uh representation like
there's a lot of like uh you can use
certain things and not certain things
not that it really matters for our at
all level but what we do is that we try
to
we try to find cast that we felt a bit
more relatable but even though she's
pretty but she's a model and all that we
still try to find the element that we
feel like she's relatable and because as
i try to explain with dna for a fashion
brand sometimes because we are consumer
facing therefore that person our client
needs to understand who she represents
so if you find someone that is a bit
like well you know she's uh i cannot
understand who is she and how is she
related to me so we don't we don't
necessarily go like oh she's a you know
a more or not or more or like she said
chinese or not chinese you just try to
choose interesting cast
but the thing is that when you are in
singapore when you cast from order you
tend to get uh good asian models and
then the the western face tends to be a
bit like
not so interesting
a lot of like just not interesting just
white and you know
just white and uh but over initially you
get a lot of like brown you know but if
i just really skin tone why it's also
like a
caucasian that might be more interesting
and very difficult to find interesting
asian models so sometimes just bringing
in the locations that we are in so it is
definitely you know not choosing because
of color just finding interesting class
and that format for us is coming from a
standpoint of is she relatable for for
us
okay so is that fun
yeah it's more fun than uh you know many
topics uh earlier so uh okay guys uh
thank you so much for a very lively
discussion and uh thank you to all the
audience who stayed with us till the end
and uh asking so many interesting
questions we actually still have quite a
lot of questions so uh to the audience
whose questions are not answered we will
try to
get the individual speakers to to
get answers and email to you um so yeah
i'm going to uh hand over to felicia of
design singapore right now to wrap up
the session thank you
all right thank you kelly thank you
nathan jin and larry for taking the time
to join us today and for sharing your
insights with us so candidly it's been
an absolute pleasure to hear from you
and to our attendees thank you for
bringing us to the end of this whole
session so
more in-depth interviews with our
speakers can be found on studio sml's
website along with the podcast on their
spotify channel so if you're keen to
find out more you can scan the relevant
qr codes that you see on your screen and
we're also going to be pasting some of
these links in the zoom chat right about
now and also studio sml's accompanying
exhibition abstract creatures is still
currently showing at la salle college of
the arts till the end of this month so
if you have some time do check that out
as well you can also view a short
documentary on the project by scanning
the relevant qr code that you see
so this is where we will all leave you
now so thank you once again for joining
us today and we hope to see you guys at
our future events take care and goodbye
thank you bye thank you thank you bye